I've been marketing for 13 years. I
built and sold nine companies. I sold my
last company for $46.2 million to
American Pacific Group. I've also
written two books on marketing that have
sold over a million copies. Here's 13
years of marketing advice that will make
you more money. Piece of advice number
one, start with low prices or even gasp
free. The reason that I say that is
because if you start there, then you can
go up. It's very difficult to come down.
And in the beginning, you want to get
flow through the system. And so, it's
totally fine to start at free and then
start bumping up from there. And so,
I'll give you three quick examples and
then I'll show you how to do this
tactically. So, when I started my first
ever business, it was a online personal
training business. This is 13-plus years
ago. And when I started, I didn't know
anything and I was so afraid to charge
people money to begin with. And so, but
I did want them to pay something cuz I
wanted them to be invested cuz otherwise
people don't follow through with their
workouts or their nutrition plans, etc.
And so, I said, "Hey, just donate to the
charity of your choice, whatever charity
you want to. In exchange, I will then
train you for 12 weeks." And so, people
would donate, I think it was $500 or
$1,000, it was their choice, to a
charity of their selection. And by doing
that, I actually got my first 13 or so
customers just by making posts and DMing
people that I knew. And it didn't feel
weird cuz I was like, "Hey, I'm doing
this kind of nonprofit thing. I want to
help you out if you want to lose weight,
and you can feel good about it, and it's
a write-off." And so, they were like,
"Oh, this is pretty cool." But the thing
is is like that was the first time I
ever did it. And then from there, I
said, "Huh, would you guys be willing to
pay me now after we finish this 12
weeks?" And a lot of them were like,
"Sure." I was like, "Yeah, I'm the
charity now." Uh and so, after I did a
good job, they were willing to do that
and refer me customers.
The next business that I did this with
was Gym Launch when I actually started
uh flying out to other gyms. So, I used
to do turnarounds and I did that for
2-plus years where I'd fly out to a gym,
set up all the pricing, do the
marketing, all that stuff. And I did it
all for free. And I did it that way
because I didn't know how I could sell
those gym owners and what I the deal
that I made was I only make money if I
make sales. And I'll front the cash for
the marketing. So, like they took zero
risk on. And I would do everything
including pay for my hotel, my flights,
my my my food, my rental car,
everything. And but being able to do
that, it allowed me to get way more
yeses quickly, test out the system in 30
plus markets that I had, which then
eventually led me to licensing that
system to 5,000 plus locations. And that
was the company that I that I sold to
APG.
The third uh time that I did this was
when I started my software company
Allen. And so, when I started the
company, I was like, I need to get some
case studies. I need some testimonials.
I need some I need some stories to show
successes, right? And so, I think a lot
of people who are in the beginning think
this is only a beginner thing. But even
if you're a big business owner, when you
start out a new product or a new
division, um starting with free
customers just makes a lot of sense. And
it's for four reasons. One is that free
customers become customers who become
paying after the period as long as you
do a good job. So, it makes money in one
way. The second way it makes you money
is that they'll also refer you customers
cuz you do a great job, they'll just
send you other people. And that can be
contingent on why you do it for free for
them. The third is that they'll leave
you testimonials and reviews. So, those
reviews and those testimonials also you
advertise and you can get more customers
from them. And then finally, whenever
you do stuff for free, I do it in
exchange for feedback. I say, "Hey, tell
me what I could do to make this better."
And again, it's not saying like tell me
all the ways I suck, it's just saying,
"Tell me how I can make this better.
Tell me how I could make it worth it for
you to want to stay and continue to
pay." And ideally,
the easy test of knowing whether or not
this works is that they actually stay
and pay afterwards. And so,
it's the easiest way to get going on any
new product and I think so many people
start trying to sell stuff too soon
without enough proof. And in the
beginning, you suck. That's why it's a
new product, a new division. And so, I'd
rather not ruin my reputation saying I'm
giving it away for free, give the reason
is that I'm brand new at this thing or
I'm trying this new thing out. And that
way I'll get a little bit of grace, and
then that way I can make the thing
better in an iterative process much
faster with way more people cuz I'm
giving it away for free or at cost. And
then once I get those massive success
stories that they feel like they owe me
because I've done a great job, then I
can market those and go at full price.
So, here's how you actually do this
tactically going from starting at low
prices to moving all the way to where
you want to be, which is high prices
with big premiums, right? And so,
what I'd say is after you have your
first test case study batch, so call it
10 or 20 people depending on the size of
your product or your services, after
that every five I just go up by 20%. And
so, let's say, okay, I started at zero
and I have a marketing agency. I might
say, okay, the first the next five I'm
going to do for a thousand bucks, right?
And then from there I might say, okay,
the next five I'm going to do for 1200
bucks. The next five I'm going to do for
1500 bucks. And you just keep going up
by 20% until the conversion rate times
the price goes down. So, that way you
can just calculate the total amount of
money made off of X number of sales
calls. And by doing that, you'll be able
to see, okay, here's the sweet spot
where I sell the most amount of units at
the highest potential price. So, my
company Gym Launch that I sold for $46
million, that company, you know, at its
peak before I was selling it, we were
taking home over a million dollars a
month in personal income.
But, that's what a lot of people think
happened the whole time, but it wasn't
like that.
The actual very first business that I
started in fitness, I actually gave away
my services for free. I actually did it
as a non-profit for charity so that I
could get clients in the door and test
out whether my stuff actually worked and
that I could deliver services. And when
you're having the conversation with
those first few people, whether you're
doing it for free or you're going to do
it for a big discount, you say, "Hey, I
plan on going to this price point, but
I'm willing to do it for free in
exchange for X," which is usually a
feedback feedback for me and a public
testimony if you're comfortable doing
it. And by having those two things, then
one, you guarantee that you get the
feedback, which is the thing you need
most, but you also can get the testimony
that you can leverage. And then finally,
you can also tack on a referral if you
want to. Again, I'd say the testimony
and the referral should be contingent on
you doing a good job. You say, "Hey, if
I do a good job, would you be willing to
do these two things?" If they say yes,
then you're good to go. The fourth one
was just, do they actually want to buy
at full price later, which will be the
real test how good you were. And I think
the bottom line here is that when you
start out, you're not that good. And
even if your ego is like kind of
convincing you that you are good, which
I think is silly,
just even imagine 2 years from now that
you're going to be much better than you
are now. Well, that guy is probably way
more experienced. So, give that guy a
running start by starting free now and
then building momentum into it. And I
have this saying that I repeat all the
time in my team, which is create flow,
monetize flow, then add friction. And
so, it's like you have to run water
through the machine. You have to get
flow into the system to see where it's
going to break so that you know what
real actually looks like rather than
just trying to get rich on Excel. The
second is the framework that I use for
scaling advertising or scaling marketing
in any niche: more, better, new.
When you're starting out, more is almost
always the answer. And so, I remember
when I was
thinking about getting into content, I I
paid someone who had made, you know, a
lot more content, had a much bigger
brand. I said, "Hey,
what should I be doing?" I like, "What
should I do to make my content better?"
And he's like, "Dude." He's like, "You
don't need to make your content better."
He's like, "You're just not making
anything." And so, what he did was he
pulled up his profile on LinkedIn and he
pulled up my profile on LinkedIn. He's
like, "I posted five times a day. You
haven't even posted." And then he pulled
up Instagram and he pulled up my
Instagram. He's like, "I posted two
times a day. You posted once a week." I
was like, "Man." He's like, "Okay, let's
pull up YouTube." And then my YouTube.
And he just went platform by platform
and he showed that he was doing 3x, 5x,
10x the volume that I was. He's like,
"Dude, you just got to do more."
And that was just like very like I felt
embarrassed cuz I just paid all this
money to have someone just look at me
and just say, "Do more." But hopefully I
can save you the money and just tell you
you probably need to do more. And the
interesting thing about this is that I
later on had like at the point now when
we had maybe this is maybe a year ago I
had five-ish million subscribers across
all platforms. I had a friend of mine
who's a billionaire who wanted to start
getting into personal branding. He said,
"Hey, man, can you check out my
Instagram and see what's, you know,
going on and why why we're not growing
as fast as I want to. And so I said,
well, before I look at it, I was like,
how many posts a week are you making
across all platforms? He's like, oh, got
that nailed. He's like, I'm posting once
a day. And I was like, dude, I was like,
we post 50 plus times a day.
And he was like,
got it. He just was like, you don't need
to say anymore. I understand. Because he
had had it enough experience in other
realms to know that like, oh, all of the
things in volume that that that work in
sales, that work in customer success,
that work in product in terms of
iterations, the same concepts apply to
advertising and marketing. Like, you
just need to do a lot in order to figure
out what works so that you can do better
later.
Now, what's interesting about this is
that this also applies on the paid side.
So, I remember there was a chiropractor
chiropractor agency that approached me.
They were doing about 2 million bucks a
year. And he was like, hey, man, I think
I've saturated Facebook.
And so I was like, and this is when it
was Facebook, not Meta. And I was like,
what do you mean? He's like, I just
think I've saturated the chiropractor
niche.
And I was like, this is a $10 billion a
year industry.
And you feel like your $2 million per
year agency has saturated Facebook. I
was like, how many I was like, do you
know of any other chiropractor agencies
that exist? He's like, yeah, there's
loads. It's like, you know, there's
hundreds of them. I was like, okay. So,
explain to me why every sale that is
keeping all of them in business is
somehow not sales that you should be
making.
He was like, got it. I was like, right,
you're spending 40 grand a month when in
aggregate all the agencies that are
selling to chiropractors are probably
spending 4 million a month. And so, all
of the spend that those businesses are
able to make in your market is your
opportunity. Is if you can outcompete
them, you can provide better service,
you can have longer LTV means you can
spend more to acquire the customer than
they can. And then you can eventually
price them out of the marketplace.
Because fundamentally, paid ads is
actually an auction for attention. And
so, people bid against each other for ad
space. And so, if you can outbid your
competition, you can have an ethical
monopoly by literally bidding more than
everyone else while still making money.
And that's the crazy thing. And that's
what fundamentally what you want to
build in terms of the mousetrap of your
business is how can I make more money
from every customer than anyone else
does so that I can spend more than
anyone else can to acquire them. And so
I had a I had a portfolio company CEO
who's a good marketer, you know, come up
to me and he was like, "Hey man, I think
we really need to scale our ads." And I
was like, "I agree."
Um and I was like, "Well, how many how
many pieces of creative are you putting
out, you know, per week?" And he's like,
"Oh, um well, I just record once a
month." I was like, "Okay, fine. Then
how many ads are you making per
session?" He was like, "Uh we do about
15. So we do about 15 new ads per
month." And I just kind of looked at
him. I was like, "Dude, when I was
trying to go from your size to five
times your size, I was making 35 a
week."
And like nowadays, we make way more than
that in terms of content and in terms of
the ads that we do like cuz I make ads
for school
and then I inform the ads across our
portfolio. And so the big saying that I
have that's like plastered on the wall
that actually applies to sales and
marketing is volume negates luck. Like
if you don't want to rely on luck and
rely on one of those 10 ads or five ads
that you make to be amazing, you just
make more ads. And I I can't tell you
the amount of times that it just reset
the bar and that's what I'm hoping to do
with this video is like the amount of
volume that the people who are ahead of
you are doing is is not 2x or 3x more.
It's oftentimes 100x more, right? Even
that the 35 times uh four, I think 140
pieces. The guy was making 15. It was 9x
the volume of what he was doing, right?
And some of you guys are making five ads
a month or one ad a month and thinking
that that's somehow going to be
sufficient to get to your goals. And
nowadays, and I'll explain later in this
how my whole ad creation process, but
just the big headline is that in the
very beginning, you just need to do a
lot more than you think you do. The
second is once you've done more, then at
what point do you start shifting to
better? And the way that you can figure
that out is when the return on effort
for better exceeds one incremental unit
of more. Meaning,
if I've got one sales guy, if I add a
second sales guy, then I think I have a
high degree of certainty that I can
probably double my sales by doing that.
But when you have 10 sales guys, adding
one more sales guy is the same level of
effort as adding going from one to two,
going from 10 to 11, but it's only a 10%
increase. And so if I can increase the
overall throughput of my entire team by
20% or 25% by tweaking some sharp rate
stuff or doing a headline split test or
or changing CTAs on my ads, then those
are things that would make me more money
per unit of effort. And so in the
beginning you usually just need to blow
as much volume through there as
possible. That's the create flow,
monetize flow, then add friction. The
The optimization steps really only
matter when you have flow going through.
And so you do more first, and then once
you're big enough, better becomes a
better return on effort. But once you
then go through the better steps, then
you usually have to go back to, "Okay,
how do we do 10 times more than we are
now? How do we go from 10 sales guys to
100 sales guys?" And that's the thinking
that you have to go through in order to
start scaling in terms of orders of
magnitude. And when you have so much
volume, you're able to iterate so much
faster. Like even us recently, we
started making uh more content on
YouTube. And we already noticed as a
team we're like, "Oh, this is awesome.
We're learning so much faster again with
like we're literally putting out four or
five videos a week instead of one video
a week." And so we're learning about
headlines and thumbnails and there's
less pressure per video because we're
like, "Cool, learn that. Let's move on
to the next one." And so it allows you
to just iterate so much faster without
getting your ego and your emotions, you
know, tied into it. Here's how I do it
is I ask the question, "What would stop
me from 10x-ing the business right now?"
And if the answer is nothing, then we
10x the business. Now, most times there
is something that would break. Like what
would break first? And so as soon as we
identify what is the first thing that
would break if we 2x, 5x, 10x, we then
isolate that thing, put all of our focus
towards fixing it, and then we do the
increase in volume.
And that is how we continue to
de-constrain until we go to the next
bottleneck, and then de-constrain that,
and then grow into the next bottleneck,
because we have a fundamental belief
that all businesses will continue to
grow until their point of constraint,
and then they will grow no further. So,
you identify the constraint, relieve the
constraint, and allow it to grow again.
Growth occurs as an aftereffect of the
inputs you put into the system. Now,
once you've done as much as you can,
more, and you've done it as well as you
can, better, when you can't do any more
any better, you start and trying
something new. And the thing that the
reason that I have new last is because
the cost of change of doing something
new is guaranteed, but the return on
something new is not. And so, I like to
say that is a big warning for the fact
that the vast majority of entrepreneurs
want to spend 80% of their time on doing
new stuff when really they should spend
90% of their time doing more and better
of what is already working for them. The
only time you do new stuff is when
nothing is working. So, when you're
starting as an entrepreneur,
everything's new, and you keep trying
and keep trying until something works.
Once it works, you have to unlearn the
whole experimentation idea, and then you
have to go, "Great, I need to do as much
as I possibly can, and do it as well as
I possibly can." And so, it's a
different mindset that you have to get
into, but that's how you start scaling.
Now, what point do you start doing
something new? Well, if you've already
said, "Okay, I can't I can't do more for
a very clear reason that there's a big
cost." Like, sometimes there's a huge
incremental cost past a certain barrier.
You're like, "Okay, I think we really
are You know, let's say you're a local a
local gym, all right? If you're a local
gym and you're spending, call it,
$10,000 a month on ads, you're reaching
every single person in your radius
multiple times a week. And so, that's on
one platform. And so, you're like,
"Okay, in order for me to scale this,
it's not really about doing more or even
doing that better. It's like, I've
saturated the crap out of the eyeballs
here." Well, that's when doing something
new will yield a higher return. You'll
get a better return on effort. And so,
that's where like, "Okay, maybe I'm
going to start doing an outbound, or
I'll start doing the paid ads, but just
on another channel. I'll start running
YouTube ads. I'll start running Google
search ads. I'll start running
um I'll start running
display ads. I'll start I'll start doing
direct mail pieces. I'll start radio
ads. Like there's a number of things you
could do in terms of other channels, but
they would be new. And so this is the
thought process that I have when I
approach that, which is if you could
double the sales of your company and it
would take a year, would you do it? But
you had to wait a year before they
doubled. Most people would say yes. If I
said you had to invest, call it half of
your profits in order to getting your
business to double, would you do it?
Yes, that'd probably be a really good
return on return on investment. If you
would put half of your profits and you
double the business, you're getting a
200% return. That's awesome, right? And
so the thing is is that people start
something new and they spend one month
of ad spend and they say, "Ah, it didn't
work. I lost money. Why would like I'm
going to stop." But the reality is that
it's going to take you 3 months, 6
months, sometimes 12 months to get the
that return to actually pay off. And
what I mark is progress, not the dollar.
So it's like, "Okay, first are we
getting clicks? Okay, we're getting
clicks. Okay, are we getting opt-ins?
Okay, we're getting opt-ins. Are the
opt-ins we're getting the right type of
people that we're looking for?" Okay,
yes. Or if they're not, then we start
tweaking the messaging, we start
tweaking the funnel until we get the
right people. Okay, now we have the
right people who are opting in. Great.
Now can we get them on the phone? Can we
get them in person? Can we get them to
show up to some sort of conversion
event, some sales event that we can then
try and sell them something, right? And
so you keep walking walking the dollar
over the bridge until eventually it
comes to the other side. But that takes
money and that takes time and that takes
learning, but it's a return on
investment because if you do double your
lead flow in a year.
One, it doubles the business. Two, it
more than doubles the value of the
business because now you have two
different ways to get customers. And so
it makes the business more stable
because if one of them goes down, then
you still have the other one. And so you
have a more stable business that's also
bigger. Market advice number three, how
to do better. And so this is double
clicking into the better concept because
this is especially for the bigger
business owners. So if you're at a few
million dollars a year to tens of
millions dollars a year, like this is
really going to start paying massive
dividends. So number one is
optimize front to back when it comes to
marketing. So, that's the 80/20. So,
David Ogilvy said famously, "After
you've written your headline, you spent
80 cents of your advertising dollar."
So, he knew that 80% of people aren't
going to do anything past read the
headline. And so, he would put 80% of
his effort towards those first few
words. And the really experienced
marketers who are watching this are like
nodding their heads right now.
The first 5 seconds, the headline, the
packaging in my history of the 13 years
that I've been doing this has only
increased. I haven't even gotten to a
sweet spot. They just continue to become
more and more important in my mind
because it's the frame through which
everyone contextualizes what they're
about to consume. So, one, it increases
the likely they consume it. Two, it
introduces the frame that they consume
the advertisement or the promotion
through. And like we now have such great
data even across on the content side
that like if we have two different
thumbnails, you can literally see the
average view duration go up by two or
three minutes sometimes simply by
changing the thumb that people click
before they watch the video. It's wild.
And so, how people the frame that people
consume the content in has a massive
impact on how effective it is. Now,
I'll tell you a quick story to show you
just how how important this is. So, a
friend of mine
Dean had this massive advertising
campaign. And he had written a new book
and he went on Larry King Live. And so,
he wanted to use the Larry King
interview to
advertise the book. And so, he shot the
whole interview and he basically wanted
Larry King to introduce him in a cool
way to make him, you know, sound cool of
course, you know, and like he would
laugh if I was if I'm telling the story
now.
And so, he knew that the ad was killer
and so, he ran it.
Spent 250 grand and nothing came back.
And he was like, "What's going on? Like
I know this
I know this ad's a killer. Like what's
happening?"
So, he went back through his old history
of ads and he looked at the top
performing ads he'd ever done. And as
soon as he started watching me, he
realized that he missed the hook, that
the hook was wrong. And so, he flew
Larry King back out. They He paid him
again. They set up a whole new set again
just to re-record the first 30 seconds.
And so, they re-recorded the first 30
seconds with the hour-long interview,
and then re-ran the infomercial, and did
a hundred million in sales.
And so, when I heard that story, I was
like, this is why that the first 5
seconds, the headline, the hook, is so
important, and that's what I spend now a
disproportion of my time on. And people
are listening to this, and you guys are
nodding along, but you're not You're
still not getting it cuz it's not real
for you. It took me forever to figure
this out. When we make ads, and I'll get
into my ad creation process later,
um
you have like I I I do 10 times the
effort on the first 5 seconds.
10 times. Actually, 10 times. So, if I
have an hour, I would I would spend 55
minutes
on the first 5 seconds, and then 5
minutes on everything that's after that.
Like, that's the proportion of how much
time I'm spending on just getting that
first part right. I'll give you a diff-
a content example of this. So, I was
invited to this
uh content creator thing
um with all the, you know, top guys.
Probably 10 guys there. Uh the lowest
guy in the room was me, and the next
lowest guy was at like 10 million plus
subscribers only on YouTube. So, they
just had me there cuz for entertainment,
who knows. Um and and I remember one of
the guys had about 15 million
subscribers, and he was pissed that this
other content creator had basically
copied his video, and and the copied
video had done better than his, like,
three times more. It got like 30 million
views, and his got like 10 million
views.
And
the main guy there, who had several
hundred million uh subscribers across
all his channels, was like, let's pop it
in. Let's Let's roast it. And so, they
press play on the video, and 5 seconds
in, he stops the video. He's like,
"Dude, you didn't confirm the thumb."
He's like, "The headline and the first 5
seconds weren't confirmed." He's like,
"I don't need to see any and he just
walked out of the room. And so this guy
had spent weeks, you know, making this
thing, obsessing about every detail of
it. He had a 20-page-plus brief on how
he was making this video and he missed
the first 5 seconds and that was the guy
who had the multiple hundred million
subscribers was like that's it and he
just walked out and got lunch. And so
when I saw that I was like, wow, like it
just reinforced how important this was.
And recently just at a micro level, one
of our portfolio companies is at
eight-figure-plus business. Um
we simply changed the headline on the
landing page, like we did nothing else.
We kept same ads, just changed the
headline. We increased booking rate by
62%. Now here's what's crazy is the
opt-in rate remained the same, but
simply because of the frame of the
promise in the headline, 62% more people
chose to book calls for that business.
And so it just shows you that how you
frame what people are then going to
consume has a massive impact on how much
value and how likely they are to take
the next step. So here's how you do it
in terms of optimizing 80/20 front to
back. So number one is assume that they
have no idea who you are, what you do,
how it works, they're in a rush and they
have a third-grade education. All right,
so clear beats clever, deletion beats
explanation. And so what you want to do
is you want to try and make it as short
as humanly possible and then once you
have it as short as possible, put it
into a third-grade reading calculator,
look at the grade level and keep editing
it down until it's third grade. Cuz the
thing is is you're not going to attract
dumber people. You're going to make
accessible to everyone. A smart person
needs to use less brain power to ex- to
understand simple language and it makes
it understandable to everyone else. And
as a reminder, 30% of people can barely
read. And so this is like relying on
them to have this skill, it's like you
want to meet them where they're at. And
there are some very rich people who can
barely read. And so it has nothing to do
with intelligence, it has everything to
do with how they were educated, which
has which may have no no connection with
their purchasing power.
Okay, and tactically what I'll do is I
probably I'd make about 50 hooks every
time I start recording ads. So, I have
50 hooks that I've written down that I
think are awesome. And then I have three
to five meat pieces of an advertisement
and then I do one to three CTAs, meaning
call to actions at the end. And so, that
means I have way more on the front end
in terms of effort compared to the one
the three to five and the one to three
that I do on the back. And that's
because I know that that's where all of
the effort needs to go cuz that's where
all the returns are. And here's the
here's the difference and this is why I
say from you optimize advertising
specifically from front to back because
it's very rare that you're going to be
able to double or triple or quadruple
the amount of throughput you get uh in a
funnel by optimizing the back end. If
you have a you know, a 30 you know, call
it a call it a 50% show rate. Okay, if
you get it to 75% that's massive, but
it's a 50% jump and that'd be a massive
increase in show rate if you did that.
But, I can absolutely get CTRs from 1%
to 4% by just optimizing the hell out of
the front end. And that's a 4x increase.
That's four times the throughput that
goes through the entire funnel. And so,
I put my effort there because you can
achieve 100% 200% 300% increases on the
front end whereas it's much more
difficult on the back end. Now, for sure
you want to optimize those things, but
if I'm going to allocate my effort, I
want to get the biggest bang for buck.
So, when you're making your hooks, I
call it a call out. So, I'm reading page
136 from my book.
A call out is whatever you do to get the
attention of your audience. Call outs go
from hyper specific to get one person's
attention to not at all specific to get
everyone's attention. So, let me
explain. If someone drops a a tray of
dishes in a party, everyone looks. If a
child yells mom, then the moms look. If
someone says your name, only you look.
But again, they all get attention. And
so, I try to make my call outs as
specific as possible to get the right
people but broad enough to get as many
of them as I can. So, pay close
attention to advertisers use call outs
especially the ones targeting your
audience. And so, what I'll do is I'll
look at all the ads from other
competitors who are targeting that same
audience as me. And the ads that are
running for long time, I know that that
call out is working well. And so, I will
write down all the call outs that I see,
and then I will write out the words that
I know my customers go by, and I'll
either start with a problem that I think
that they're struggling from or a
question that I think that I know that
they'll say yes to, or I'll simply state
moms in Nevada, homeowners in Clark
County, right? Very clearly calling out
this is for you. And that's exactly what
you want the person to say when they
read the headline or hear the call out,
this is for me.
And the more specific you get, often
times you'll be surprised. You think
that going as broad as you can is going
to increase the number of opt-ins, but
when you get really specific about the
type of customer you're really trying to
attract, you will often find that
they're like, "Oh, I wouldn't have
responded to the broad thing, but this
one's just for me." And you get more
people in terms of qualified leads in
the door by being more specific. Piece
of advice number four, LTV to CAC is the
only thing that matters. And if I had
only one metric that I could find out
about a business, if I only had one that
I could pick, it would be the LTV to CAC
ratio. And let me tell you a quick story
that will kind of drive this home. So, a
friend of mine owns a bow manufacturing
business, and they do, you know, 20 30
million bucks a year, so relatively
large business, established. And he was
like, "Hey, we're trying to get into
paid ads." Now, they had all these
distribution relationship, but they want
to open up this new channel. And he
says, "Hey, you're the, you know, you're
the marketing guy, right? So, can you,
you know, what what would you do here?"
And so, as I was explaining the the
process that I that I the strategy that
I wanted to outline for him, he was
like, "Well, what's the benchmark I
should be looking at in terms of leads?"
And I was like, "Dude, the benchmark is
irrelevant. It everything just comes
back from what's gross profit." So, he's
like, "Okay, so what's the average gross
profit on a bow?" I'm making this up.
Say it's $500. Okay, so if we get leads
for, call it, 20 bucks, and we know that
we can get one in five leads to buy a
bow, then it means it cost us, our CAC
is $100, and our gross profit from
selling each bow is $500. So, it cost us
$100 to make $500 of gross profit, five
to one. Awesome. And so, fundamentally,
is $20 a good lead cost? Well, yeah,
he's getting five to one. If it was at
$10, uh then he'd be getting 10 to one.
And that's assuming the same ratios. And
so, it just depends on what percentage
of customers you convert and at what
price point you're converting them at.
CAC to LTV or CAC to LTGP. So, I use
LTGP to be more specific. Lifetime value
is just the amount of gross profit you
make from a customer over the lifetime
of them being a customer of your
business. CAC is the cost to acquire a
customer, which is the all-in cost,
including sales, marketing, software,
everything, to get somebody to give you
money. And so, the CAC to LTV ratio is
simply how much money it costs you to
make more money. It's the foundational
economic unit of any business. And so,
making sure that you know how much money
it costs you to make money, that
fundamentally feels like a very
important metric in order to scale the
business. And over time, as long as you
don't have uh some big capital expenses
in terms of scaling your business, that
fundamental return that you get will
reflect the compounding growth of the
business provided you don't have other
constraints to growth. So, for example,
if I have meals that I sell for $10 and
it cost me $9 to package and ship them
and deliver them, then I have $1 of
gross profit per meal. And so, if
someone buys 10 meals for me, I'm not
making $100, I'm making $10 in gross
profit. And if the average person buys,
call it, five weeks of meals, then I
would make $50 in lifetime gross profit.
And so, the only way that I would want
to be able to acquire customers is that
the cost to acquire a customer in this
example, I don't want to have probably
at $15 or less. Cuz you can't do it at
even because then there's no money left
over to do everything else in the
business. And so, the rule of thumb is
that you want to have at least three to
one on LTV to CAC. But again, LTV is not
lifetime revenue, it's lifetime gross
profit, right? And that's what people I
think a lot of times mess up is they
don't even know what their gross profit
is, and then they spend blindly.
So, I'll tell you a fun one. So, if
you've seen Starbucks advertise, now a
lot of them they just use their
storefronts as their advertising at this
point, but they make about $14,000
in LTV per customer. And so they can
spend absurd amounts of money to get
customers in the door. Like even if it
cost them $500, they're still making
28:1 on the money they put in. And that
is why that company's been able to scale
to the moon in terms of the number of
locations. And so I will say that the
all the money that I've made in my life
that has been the crazy money has come
from crazy LTV to CAC ratios. And so the
smallest ratios that I've made crazy
money on is 30:1 all the way up to 100:1
to 200:1 returns in some of the
businesses I have. And so those those
windows don't stay forever. And when you
do have one of those, you just want to
dump as much money into that machine as
you possibly can because a lot of wealth
is made in very short punctuated periods
and then sustained by long periods of
maintenance where you're getting 5:1,
8:1, 10:1. Those are fine numbers. But
most of the time when you're at 10:1, as
soon as you start scaling it, it might
drop to 5:1. And so I actually end up
seeing the bigger the ratio is at the
beginning, the more indication it is
that I can scale profitably. Because if
I'm let's say spending, you know, $1,000
a day and I can get 100:1, then I know
that I'm probably going to be able to
get to $100,000 a day and get 5:1,
right? And so that's the idea is like
how can I how can I scale this up? And I
care about absolute return, not relative
return, but the CAC to LTV ratio gives
me an indication of how much room I have
to blow this thing out of the water. The
easiest way to calculate what your
lifetime gross profit is is look at all
the customers that you sold over the
last year, look at gross profit. And if
you don't know what gross profit is,
it's just the cost of goods sold
basically the price you charge minus the
cost of goods sold, which is whether
it's if it's services, then it's the
labor that you use to provide the
service. If it's a widget, then it's the
cost of the widget and the shipping
associated with it. So the cost of goods
sold minus the revenue and that left
over is the gross profit. And so you
say, "Okay, I had 100 customers this
year. I made this total amount of gross
profit this year." You divide that
amount of gross profit by the total of
number of customers. That'll give you a
broad brush stroke of what you make per
customer. Now, that'll always
underestimate it, especially if you have
a recurring revenue business, because
they're going to hopefully have some
people who buy again and again over
time. But, I would always rather be on
the safer side and underestimate my
lifetime gross profit or lifetime value,
rather than overestimate and potentially
lose money. If I want to then take that
number and say, "Okay, well, what am I
willing to spend per customer?" then at
most you want to have a third of that
number. But, for me specifically, I want
to make sure that whatever I collect in
the first 30 days, I want to make sure
that I collect that back from customers.
So, if I'm Let's say I sell something
for 10 bucks a month, people stay for 10
months, and there's a 100% gross margins
to make this simple. So, I make 100
bucks in gross profit. I want to see if
I can find a way to make $10 back or get
my CAC back in that first 30 days. And
so, sometimes it means having a one-time
upcharge up front so they can offset the
cost of acquisition, so then the
remainder of the customer relationship
can be profitable. And if these concepts
about scaling, like LTV to CAC, are
interesting to you, we just opened up a
new workshops division at
acquisition.com for companies that we're
not invested in. If you'd like us and my
team to help you personalize kind of
applying this stuff to your business,
you can go to acquisition.com, click the
scale button, and you can see if your
business qualifies. Otherwise, back to
the video. Piece of advice number five,
my ad creation process. So, I've been
running ads for 13 years. And I'm saying
when I say running ads, I mean like I've
been making ads or directly influencing
ads that have been run across my
portfolio or companies that I directly
owned or founded for 13 straight years.
And so, I have this process pretty
nailed. And I haven't really ever gotten
too far away from it, partially cuz I
like it a lot, um and I've gotten just
pretty good at it. And so, this is how I
do it. So, number one is that at all
times I'm collecting data. What I mean
by that is like, if I see ads on
Instagram, I see ads on YouTube, like I
have no pre-mic accounts on any
platform, cuz I want to hear the ads. I
want to hear the hooks. I want to hear
what they're doing to draw attention.
And I like using that stuff because I'm
also a business owner. So, the people
who advertise to me are the people that
are going to try and hook my attention.
And so, I can still use that stuff to
get to my avatar. And so, if you are
your avatar, the ads count double for
you. And so, I I I I screenshot, I
record the stuff that I find
interesting. And I add it into one
folder. Then, when I get to my ad
creation process, which is I do once a
week, I then sit down first thing in the
morning and I do these the same day I
record. So, that's just a piece of
advice that that has worked well for me,
like cramming for the test. I cram for
my ad sessions cuz then everything's top
of mind as I go into the day. And so, I
pull up all my swipe files of all the
things that I want, like my inspiration
from. The second thing that I pull up is
all my historical best-performing ads.
So, I look back 1 year, 2 years, 3
years, sometimes at all my best ads. And
I drink those back in and and I watch
the first 10 seconds, watch the first 30
seconds to see, okay, how was it
capturing? What was the angle? What was
the hook here? And then, I start the
actual hook creation process. Now, 40 of
my 50 hooks that I'm going to write out
are going to be stuff that is tried and
true. I'm not going to try and reinvent
the wheel. We've already spent zillions
and zillions of dollars. I know that
these hooks, these entrances work well.
Now, 20%, the last 10 is where I get to
use all my inspiration and other ideas
to try and experiment on. But, most
people flip this. They try and do a
little bit of the stuff that worked and
then they have lots of new ideas. I'm
telling you, I've done this a long time.
It's way more efficient to just do more
of what worked and then leave a little
bit experimentation so that if some of
those things stop working over time, you
have this fresh batch that you've been
trying out that then can become the
control that you try and beat. So,
citing back to the 80/20 concept of you
put 80% of your effort into the hooks
and 80% of your effort goes into stuff
that's tried and true and 20% for the
things that are new. All right. So, I
make about 50 hooks. So, 80% of that is
40 hooks and 20% of that is 10 hooks.
So, 40 out of my 50 hooks, I do for
things that I already know have worked
in the past.
10 hooks I save for my new creative
ideas. And so, that's for the
inspiration stuff that I see or or that
I come to that cram session that I want
to get out. From there, I then have my
three to five angles that I'm going to
write that's going to be educational or
some sort of value that I'm going to
deliver or some sort of belief that I
want to break or some sort of list or
steps or stories that I want to tell as
the core meat of the ad, some sort of
proof I want to demonstrate, and then
finally just a quick CTA in terms of
call to action. But the majority of my
effort is all on the 50 or so hooks that
I'm going to write, 40 of which being
recycled versions of things I already
know work, and 10 being net new. And
this sounds boring, and it is boring,
but it's also what works. And believe
me, I have tried to change this process
a lot of times. Like, this works.
Let's say that you have your a mega
winner. And these happen. And this is
where you get This is the This is power
law. Like that top 5% makes 95% of your
income. Like you we run all these ads to
figure out which is the one ad that can
sing and just crank and print money. And
so what I do is I I use something that I
call the kaleidoscope process. I've
never heard anyone else sell it, so I'm
owning that title. All right. And so the
kaleidoscope process This is how you do
it. Is that let's say you've got a
winning ad. So I had an ad at Gym Launch
that actually the now president Kale
made when he was a a customer of him in
front of his gym, the gym being full,
and his wife's next to him, and he's
like, "You know, 6 months ago, I was
working a full-time job in order to pay
rent at this gym, and my wife was
pregnant, and we had and I had a
2-month-old, and I had no idea how I was
going to make ends meet. And then here
we are 6 months later, the gym is full,
it's completely outsourced, and I've
already got an offer for $250,000 on the
gym. If you've ever been worried like
take the jump, just follow the process,
it works." Right? It's a very simple ad.
But it murdered. It absolutely crushed.
And so, rather than say, "Wow, okay.
Well, that was nice. Let's try and do
that Let's try and get somebody else to
say that." We took that and we squeezed
the living life out of it. And so here's
10 things that I did to get more out of
that ad. So one is I changed the color
of the backgrounds if I can do that,
right? Or backdrops. Is there a way that
we can record that ad with a different
background or a different background
color like if you had a green screen.
Second, is are there different props
that we can introduce that ad? All
right, so can we show stuff? Can we Can
we show visuals or we can show physical
props? Three, can we just reenact it?
Just say, "Hey, Cal, can you just do it
again? Just literally do the same ad,
different t-shirt if you want, same
exact thing, just do it again." And if
you're the one making the ads, you just
do your best-performing ad again. You
can four, reorder it. So, we took the ad
that was already the original winner,
and we just re- rechanged the order up
of the ad, and it still converted. The
next things we added visual filters. So,
think black and white, think sepia,
think high contrast, low contrast. These
are all different things that made the
ad look different than it was, but it
still delivered the same message. The
next one was visual effects, right? VFX,
like doodads and and wizbangs and things
like that that you can add to, again,
make it look different.
The next is changing fonts and captions.
So, it's like if we had a font style
that was one way, we just changed the
way the font style looks. Another is
that you can change the pacing or the
speed of the video itself. You can
actually do it at 1.2 or 1.5 and have it
go through or slow it down at portions.
You can add music to it. Um there's
another one, right? You can also use the
same hook, which is like we knew the
hook from that first ad obviously
crushed, and then just say, "Hey,
re-record it again. We'll use the same
hook and use a different back." Right?
And so, all of those are different ways
that will take a winner and then 10x or
100x how much that winner gets us. And
I'm telling you, if you if you take one
thing from this video from advertising,
squeeze the living hell out of the
winners. So, marketing advice number six
is that there is only four ways that you
can let other people know about your
stuff. And so, think about this like a
four-box. You've got one-to-one
conversations and one-to-many, which is
broadcast, right? There's the two styles
of communicating. You either communicate
to a group of people or one person
individually. And you're either talking
to people who know who you are or you're
talking to strangers. And so, if you
cross that, you've got four ways. You've
got one-to-one to people who know you,
one-to-one to strangers, one-to-many to
people who know you, one-to-many to
strangers. And if you look at that in
terms of what that is in advertising, it
means this is warm outreach, cold
outreach, making content, which is
one-to-many to people you know, and then
running ads, which is one-to-many to
strangers. And so, those are the only
four things that you can do to
advertise, to let people know about your
stuff. And basically, if you're not
spending your day doing one of those
core four things, you are not
advertising. You are not marketing your
business. And so, sometimes it gets you
have to get it to that simple when you
look at how many hours per day am I
spending letting people know about my
stuff, most people spend zero zero zero
per day letting people know about their
stuff, and then for some reason they're
curious as to why their business isn't
growing. Well, no one knows you exist. I
was at a conference I was at Gym Con
recently, and I asked the audience, "Who
here wants to grow their gym faster?"
Everybody raised their hand. And I said,
"Okay." And these are all small
businesses. So, these are most of the
guys here are doing I would say $500,000
a year to $3 million a year. So, these
aren't massive businesses. They're
normal, you know, one location, three
location, five location owner operators
of service-based, you know, training
businesses.
And I said, "Okay.
Who here is spending the first 4 hours
of their day
promoting their business, either doing
cold outreach, making content, or
running ads?
Who is spending the first 4 hours every
day on that? Literally, no one in the
audience had their hand raised.
And I was like, "This is why you're
small." Like, this is it. Like, it was
mind-blowing to me that that was what it
was. And so, if you're if you're making
less than call it a million, maybe $3
million a year, like all of your effort,
the the first 4 hours of your day, which
if you have to wake up early, awesome.
If you have to stay up late to do it,
awesome. I don't care, but you need 4
hours that you're dedicating because you
got to you got to do the job of
promoting, and then you got to run your
business. But, if you're just running
your business, you're never going to get
ahead.
So, if you want it to grow, you got to
force it to grow. You have to force
people to find out about your stuff, and
you do that through advertising. I
recommend this so violently because
small businesses need to do more.
And in the beginning, they just don't
get enough leads. So, fundamentally,
like most businesses, if you just had
more leads, you would make more money.
Now,
realistically, and I'll get to some of
the some of the specifics on this, is
that in order to get more leads, you
need to be able to do so profitably,
which then comes back down to the
business and building the business back
to front. We advertise front to back, we
build the business back to front, and
I'll get to lots of details on that in a
second.
But big picture,
you just need to get, especially when
you're starting out, you're at 500 to a
million, you know, less than 3 million.
And those are big numbers. I don't say I
don't mean that to demean it, but I want
you to build massive enterprises that
make huge impact.
You have to get more flow through the
system so that you can learn how to
improve the product so that you can
build a better back end. And then you
basically you promote and you stay at
that level of promotion until you tweak
this and nail it. Then you go back and
scale it. And so one of our sayings
internally is nail it, then scale it. So
nail the back end, you do enough
promotion to get flow in, right? Then
you monetize, then you create fiction.
That's when you tweak the hell out of
it, and then you can go back and say,
"Hey, turns out we can spend five times
more to get customers." Then you scale.
So I'll give you my quick back of napkin
scaling framework for this. So when
you're at zero to six figures, you sell
one product to one avatar on one
channel. That's it. No shiny object, no
multiple channels, no trying to scale
yourself out of it. You're just selling
one product to one avatar on one
channel. When you go from six to seven
figures, you scale you sell one product
to one avatar on one channel
consistently. Because in the beginning
you're super volatile, right? You're not
you're making a sale this week, not next
week, then this week again or the next
month, whatever. It's super volatile.
When you get to seven figures, it's more
consistent. You just you you get it to
be reliable. So when you go from seven
figures to eight figures, you go one
avatar, one channel, two products. That
means you have an upsell, you sell
something else.
And then you do that consistently,
right? That's what gets you to eight
figures. That's what gets you to 10
million bucks a year. And if you want to
go to, you know, multiple eight figures,
then you start going two channels, one
avatar, two products consistently. And
so over time, this is how I've seen I've
just seen this pattern. Now, can you
find somebody who disobeys this pattern?
Sure. AG1 has one product, one avatar, a
zillion channels, right? So, yes, there
are ways to break this rule. But, when I
look at by and large, the vast majority
businesses, they follow this structure,
and they mess up along the way until
they follow the next step. And you'll
notice that scaling up to eight figures,
and even sometimes a little beyond that,
you're still only focused on one avatar.
And I'm going to talk about this in a
lot of depth in one of the later advice
points because it's super important and
this may be one of the bigger unlocks
you could have in the business.
Marketing advice number seven, state the
facts and tell the truth. This is
probably one of the most repeated
phrases besides volume negates luck that
I have internally to my business. And
so, I remember when I was at that same
little meetup with uh the super
creators, and I was I was talking to the
the the guy who had the the most, you
know, subscribers there, and I was like,
"Yeah, you know, like we don't really
like this whole clickbait title thing."
And he looked at me with disgust, and he
was like, "You absolutely make clickbait
titles." He said, "You just back it up
with truth." He said, "So, it's crazy
clickbaity." He said, "But, it also
happens to be true." And I remember when
he said that to me, I was like, "Shit,
that's that's real."
And it's funny because that was a
concept that I have in terms of uh paid
ads, but I hadn't thought about it in
terms of content. And so, it's so
interesting how some of these principles
just apply across across domains, but
like sometimes you have to relearn the
same lessons, which I hate doing, but I
did it anyways. And so,
the problem is that most businesses
don't track results. And it's because if
you don't track, you don't care. Now,
they don't track partially because if
they it's kind of like ignorance. Like,
they know they don't deliver good
results, and so if they track it, then
they'll have facts and truth that they
will be proven that they're delivering
bad results. But, the first step is
tracking it. Because once you start
tracking it, you can improve it. And
measurement as intervention is actually
a scientifically proven method to lose
weight, to improve sales, to improve
anything you want. You can literally
simply tracking it, not trying to do
anything else, but simply tracking your
weight, simply tracking your close rate,
simply tracking your ad performance will
improve it because you're just putting
attention on it. And so, if you don't
track, you don't care. Now, once you do
start tracking it, you can start doing
things to actually improve it beyond
just measurement as intervention. And
so, when you do that, lo and behold,
your stats get better. And then, you can
state the facts and tell the truth and
have that truth be wildly compelling.
And so, real talk,
part of the reason that GymLaunch to
this day has still not been beaten or
dethroned as the the the largest company
in that space is because we still have
better stats and better results than
anyone else does. The average gym who
goes through 12 months of GymLaunch
makes over 100 plus thousand a year in
added profit by using the systems we
have. That's just what it is. And so,
like if someone if it makes sense for
somebody to triple their money, then
they make the they make the purchase,
right? It's It's I like to take a lot of
emotion out of the sale. Like if this
makes sense for you, if this return
makes sense for you, then do it. If it
doesn't make sense, then don't do it.
Now, the risk they take on is what about
the bottom 20%? And so, the nice thing
is that we track that. So, the bottom
20% average $40,000 in additional
revenue. So, they basically broke even.
And so, it's like that's the bottom. And
so, like if if if that's you, then it's
like, yeah, you worked and you basically
broke even. That kind of sucks. Now, I'm
not talking about the top 20% cuz this
guy's at 500,000 plus per year. But, the
thing is is that if you track the stats,
then you can promote the stats and you
can do so truthfully. They go from
unsubstantiated claims to substantiated
claims. Like one of the things that I'm
most proud of in school, uh school.com,
which is the platform for people who are
trying to start their business, this is
this video is mostly for people who
already own a business, but if you're
trying to start a business, um 30.44% of
people who finish their first month make
their first dollar online. Like I'm
super proud of that. And we just rolled
out this massive new thing um to
basically make it even easier, even
faster to do it. And right now we have
35% more people actually succeeding
there. So, I think we're going to be at
a little bit over 40% now. Um so, I'm
super stoked about that. But like,
unless you measure, like if you don't
track, you don't care. Here's the
tactical steps.
Collect data
first. So, you implement a data step
where you collect data from people day
one, day 30, day 60, day 90, at the end
of the program, or whatever your
implementation is.
You track data throughout. Number two is
you keep improving things until the data
becomes compelling. And number three is
how do you actually present that data?
So, there's four variables that matters
when you're presenting the data. Number
one is the percentage of people, whether
that's the median, the average, or the
percentage overall of people, that's
number one, who two achieve X outcome,
three in Y time or after X attempts, and
four under Z conditions. And so, it's
like we get X percent of gyms, so as
whatever is the average average gym, so
right, average gym owner makes
an extra $100,000 per year in profit, so
that's the outcome,
after their first 12 months in GymLord,
right? And so, those are the conditions,
right? And so, it covers all four of
those. So, so when you're making these,
you want to you want to hit all four of
those things when you're explaining the
data publicly. And I will say that the
fewer conditions you have, the more
compelling it is. Because for example,
if I said,
uh the average gym who spends $10,000 a
month and has 10 employees and uh has
two two methods of acquisition and a
large group training and a small group
training achieves the like I'm by the
time I even get to that, you're like,
whatever, right? And so, you want to you
want to strip away and really like I
would rather have a fewer condition
statement that has lower results me
personally than a higher result one with
more conditions.
Marketing advice number eight, say what
only you can say, show what only you can
show. And this is one of the other isms
that I have internal to my business. And
so, if you're the only triple black belt
in Ohio for Muay Thai, then say that
you're the only triple black belt in
Ohio for Muay Thai, right? This is
talking about the things that you have
done rather than telling people what to
do. It's how I versus how to. And so, my
my concept for making amazing ads and
making amazing content is two steps. Do
epic stuff, talk about what you did. And
so, you can out out come people or you
can out work them. So, it starts with
the out working and then the out working
creates the out out coming and the out
out coming is a much shorter headline,
but the out working them still works,
right? I can start by saying, "Hey, I I
put I wrote these two books." Writing
two books would be an out working thing.
Like, anyone could do it. There's no
outcome, but hey, I wrote these two
books. But then if the books are good,
then I get the outcome, which is that we
sold over a million copies. They're
still number one and number two in
marketing to this day multiple years
later. And so, the idea is that first
you do the work and then you get the
outcome, but most people want to say
epic stuff having done none of it. And
so, you can get past the judgment of
other people because you're not saying,
"Hey, you have to do anything." I'm
saying, "This is what I did." And so,
the idea is that everybody wants a
return on their time. All right? And I
remember hearing this first concept from
Erac, who's a YouTuber. And he said,
"Dude, I made this thing where I went on
100 dates in
basically did an entire season of The
Bachelor, but I did it in 16 minutes."
He's like, "What a steal." And he said
that to me and I was like, "Man, such an
interesting concept." Like, he just took
something that was really long and made
it really short and he crammed it in
there. So, value per second was super
high. And I'll just give you this one is
that it's not about seconds of value,
it's value per second. That's what
matters. Like, everybody has access to
infinite information. So, you just
saying I'm going to give you more stuff
is not helpful. What you want to do is
curate it and pack it and distill it and
crystallize all the value in as tight a
package as humanly possible so that
their value per second skyrockets. And
you can do that by saying, "Hey, I spent
10 hours editing, you know, you know, I
spent I spent 20 hours making a summary
of this book and you can read the whole
thing in 10 minutes." That's why
summaries still always work, right?
Because people want to get a a deal on
their time. If they get the same result
for a fraction of the time, it's always
a good deal. By the way, if you ever
want to sell to rich people, just
promise the same result in half the time
for twice the price. And even if you
think about this video overall, it's
like, well, I spent 13 years doing all
this stuff and I'm trying to compress
those lessons into whatever amount of
time this video is, certainly less than
13 years. And so, this is a great deal
for the right person, for the right
business owner who's actually trying to
scale. So, how do you actually do this?
So, if I had a marketing agency showing
what only I can show, I want to
demonstrate. And so, rather than say,
"Hey, I'm going to get you leads." what
I want to do is get them a sales call
and I'm going to play what a live lead
that I got for one of my companies, one
of my clients sounds like. And I'd be
like, "Hey, listen to this call. It's a
minute long. Do you think you could how
much could you take 50 of these a
month?" Wow, so much more compelling
than saying, "I'll just get you 50
leads." They're actually getting a a
fractionalized version. They're getting
a taste of what it looks like to be in
the future, right? They're experiencing
the result vicariously through the other
person. And fundamentally, that's what a
good testimony does is they they put
themselves in the shoes of the person
who got the result and then they account
they they put a discount on that and
say, "Okay, how how likely is that for
me?" And that's what I'm willing to pay.
Now, if it were guaranteed, then all
money-making opportunities would be
worth it because, hey, if you spend a
thousand dollars to make a hundred
thousand dollars a year by buying this
course, then everyone would buy it if
they knew for sure it would happen.
That'd be an amazing deal. The problem
is that people apply a discount to it
because of how unlikely it is for them.
And so, we want to increase that
likelihood by showing them rather than
telling them, right? And so, agency
example, that was that one. The software
example that I have is this is why demos
are so effective, right? That you want
to see this Hey, you have a a video
clipping software. Great. Do you have a
video on you? Cool. Send it to me. We're
on the phone. Great. I'm going to pull
this video up. This is what we do to put
the captions on and and shorten and find
those moments. Click, click, click,
click, click. Okay, so normally, how
long does that take you? Well, it takes
me this long. Well, watch me do it.
Click, click, click. Wow, would that
make your life easier? Yes. Cool. Boom.
They go in, right? You're demonstrating
in advance. And I'll give you a final
one. When I was at my gym
in Huntington Beach, it was my first
location I ever had. I remember this I
had a door-to-door sales guy who came
up, all right? And this guy was a clear
sale a pro. He was really good.
Um and he sold me cleaning products. He
really did. Like it's the it's probably
the only door-to-door thing I've ever
bought. And it was just cuz it was such
a good it was such a good sale. And he
had it down it's so tight. I think he
was in and out in like 13 minutes. Like
it was stupid. And so he just said,
"Hey, I've got this stuff. It'll take
care of any stain that you've got on
this floor." And I had turf. And so I
had gum that I got in the turf it was
really black and like gone in there. And
so he just took that thing and he poured
it on the gum and he just got on his
hands and knees he scrubbed it and it
actually came out. And the gum was
actually impossible to get out. And I
was like, "Wow." Like he I didn't have
to think, "Will this work for me?" He
just did it in front of me on a stain I
actually had. He was like, "Cool. Looks
like you got 20 other stains. If this is
worth it, it's a 100 bucks for this
stuff." So I paid 100 bucks for some
cleaning supplies, but it was totally
worth it, right? And I ended up using
that stuff for actually years cuz I had
the he sold me huge gallons of
it, right? Um and so again, it's
whenever you can and don't say, "Oh,
this doesn't work for my business." Try
and imagine, "How can I make this work
for my business?" Show them what what
they will experience and do it in a way
that no one else can do it. And so for
example me, I the reason I say like do
epic stuff and then talk about it is
that you continue to live life every
day. And so things continue to happen.
And so you can use the things that
happen that you're doing as the content
that you're making. And the content will
always be shorter than the amount of
time it took for the thing to happen.
And so we have a portfolio of companies.
And so I share case studies on this
channel of like, "Hey, here's how we
added 40 sales guys. Here's how we, you
know, increased, you know, we cut cut
refunds by 2/3. Here's how we XYZ." And
it's cuz we're doing stuff and then we
just talk about what we did. And so the
key point step one is do stuff and then
step two talk about it. Everyone else is
stuck in the step where they don't want
to they want to figure out what to talk
about, but it's because they haven't
done anything. If you do stuff, you have
more than enough to talk about.
Marketing truth number nine, how and
when to expand your market. There's five
ways. Now big picture, the vast majority
of people need to do way more with their
current market. So just to give you
context on this, I had a a guy who came
out to a workshop and he said, "Hey, I
I'm a coach who coach coaches, right?"
And I was like, "All right, fine." And
he said, "I'm spending, you know, I'm
making 2 million bucks a year. It's a
really saturated space, so I think
should I go broader?"
It's a general business. And I was like,
"Dude, how many coaches coaching coaches
exist?" He was like, "Zillions." And I
was like, "Dude, I think you just need
to get better."
Because if you were the best coach of
coaching coaches, then you would be able
to take all of the market share that all
of those guys have and it would come to
you, right? Winner takes all if you're
the best. And so, just to give you an
example, and this is the one I gave him.
I said, "Gym Launch. Everyone knows it's
a gym company, but you don't know how
niche it really is. So, one, we didn't
work with personal trainers. Number two,
we didn't work we do now, but we didn't
for the first four or five years work
with big box facilities. So, large, you
know, facilities where you pay, you
know, $10 to 70 bucks a month to have
access to the the pool, the racquetball
thing, the cardio area, the weights,
basketball, whatever.
We we didn't work with them at all. I
call this facility leasing. We didn't
use those. We didn't work with yoga. We
didn't work with spin. We didn't work
with Pilates.
We literally only worked with
micro gyms that did before and afters of
weight loss and transformations. They
had to do fitness and weights or some
combination of those. That was it.
That's a niche of a niche of a niche.
And that business still cranks out 30
plus million dollars a year. All right?
And so, the idea here is that
you want like the market, if you are the
best, is still massive. You just need to
solve the thing that matters most, which
is being the best. Now, if you have
solved being the best, there's five ways
that you can expand. And so, I'll tell
you what we did cuz Gym Launch has
expanded. I told you now we do do big
box, but there's five ways you can
expand. One, I think about it like a
pyramid. So, let's say you're in the
middle. You can go up market, meaning
you go to higher value customers. So,
for us that would be health clubs, the
big boxes like I was talking about,
multi-location owners or franchisors.
Those would be going up market, more
valuable but fewer of them, like the
pyramid. On the other hand, you can go
down market. I could go after personal
trainers. I didn't go after them. We
don't go after them. But, if I wanted
to, that would be a move that I could
make. I would have to sell a lot more
volume at a lower price and build the
infrastructure to support that kind of
volume. I could go adjacent, which would
be, "Okay, I've got gyms. I'll do
chiropractors. I'll do Or I've got gyms
and I can do weight loss uh clinics,
right? Or medspas or something like
that." So, something that's adjacent
that serves a similar avatar, but a
slightly different business model. That
would be adjacent. And the fifth way you
can do it is that you actually go
narrower. So, that was the fourth way.
So, the fourth way is you can go
narrower, which is say, "Okay, instead
of all gyms or just microgyms that
service uh before and afters, I say I
only do, you know, uh
ones that do weights. Or I only do ones
that only do cardio, right? Or I only do
boot camps. Or I only do semi-private."
Like, I niche down even more. The
alternative is that you go broader and I
say anyone that's in health and
wellness.
And so, those are the five ways that you
can spend. You can go up market, you can
go down market, you can go adjacent
market, you can go narrow, you can go
broad. Now, despite me saying these five
ways of expanding and everyone gets
their juices, you know, their jollys off
thinking about how they're going to
expand, most time I'm going to start
with that original story, which is that
you can make 10, 20, 50 million dollars
a year just serving one very specific
avatar. And the vast majority of
businesses, this is including portfolio
companies that we purchased, I would say
I would say more than half the portfolio
companies we've purchased, we did this
exercise and we made the avatar
narrower. We got more specific, not
broader. I learned this process from
Vista Private Equity. So, if you don't
know who they are, they're a hundred
billion dollar plus private equity, one
of the most successful private equity of
all time. They focus on software
companies. And I talked to their head of
pricing and packaging and he gave me
this one line and it changed my life. He
said, "You want to know how we get the
crazy returns that we do?" And I was
like, "Yeah, obviously I want to know
what you guys do." Now, obviously they
do lots of things, but the one thing
that he pulled out, he said, "We just
know the company that we're buying's
customers better than they do. And so,
we get we go into the data rooms.
Whenever you're doing an acquisition,
there's something called a data room.
You put all the data for your business
in there so people can analyze it and
make a decision about whether they want
to invest." And so, we go into the data
room and we analyze all their customers
and we say, "Okay,
we order them by who pays the most and
who's worth the most." We say, "This is
the 20% that does 80% of the revenue."
And what they do is they look at what
channels those people come in on, what
offers, what marketing those customers
do. And they basically stop doing the
rest of the 80% and then they expand
that 20% to be 100% of the business. And
so by doing that, they can have the same
size business but 5x the revenue.
And arguably even more on the profit.
And so just Pareto law, the the Pareto
principle, 80/20 and they just apply it
to the customers. And so right now, this
is how you do it for you, is you look at
all the customers you have up to this
point, you look at the top 20% and you
say, "Okay, what do these people all
have in common?" And so I like to think
about this in terms of psychographics,
what do they think, geographics, where
do they live, demographics, what do they
look like, and then I would say like
actions, like what have they done or
what did they do to get this result. And
so when I look at each of those frames,
I try and eliminate as many variables as
I can so I get to two or three variables
that that clump all the best customers
together. And then I make that in my
marketing and I tell my sales team, "We
only sell these people going forward."
Because I know that these people are
worth five times more or 10 times more.
And then guess what is able to happen?
We run ads for those people and then our
LTV skyrockets so we can spend more to
acquire customers and this is what
allows you to scale by going narrower.
And so the problem is that most business
owners can't say no to fast money and so
they never get the big money.
And so I had two companies that came out
for a workshop uh that we had and um one
they were both agencies. It was a very
simple example. So one was a generalist
agency. They just did anybody who
knocked on the door they would they
would take their money. The other one
just did professional services. So
that's legal, financial, insurance, like
those types of services.
And the the generalist guys I said,
"Okay, you have this big list of
customers. I'm sure that there's a sub
segment of those customers that you do
exceptionally well with." They're like,
"Oh my god, we crush it for IT people."
And I was like, "Okay, cool." So what
percentage of your customers are those?
They're like, "8%." I was like, "But are
they more profitable by percentage?"
He's like, "Oh, by a mile. They're by
far the most profitable." I was like,
"Okay. So if your entire business" and
they were really struggling in terms of
infrastructure, they were like super
stressed out, you could see it. I was
like, "If your whole business was just
those, do you think you would like that
business?" And he was like, "Oh my god,
that would be a breeze." And I was like,
"Well, then we can build that business."
And so, that means that from here on out
you only sell those people. And over
time, the slight the percentage of the
pie that's those customers is going to
continue to increase until eventually
you can cut the customers that are not
your main thing. And then, in a year or
2 years you've completely transformed
your business into something that's been
productized, you get really efficient,
you get even better at it cuz you only
serve those customers, you get better at
acquiring them, get better servicing
them, you get higher margins, and you
actually like your life. And so, the
same thing happened with the second
agency where I said, "What are the
customers you have?" And they're like,
"Actually, we're really good at
specifically family law attorneys, so
like divorce attorneys." And they had
all these other things. I was like, "But
divorce attorneys you're really good
with." And they're like, "Yeah." I was
like, "Then just sell divorce
attorneys." And because the thing is, if
you just sell divorce attorneys, it's a
multi-billion-dollar per industry. Like,
there's no reason you can't do a hundred
million dollars a year or two hundred
million dollars a year just selling
those people. And the same with the IT.
So, the idea is like people start taking
on more avatars cuz they think that's
what's necessary to grow. But
And I've said this before, but better
creates bigger. Bigger creates bloat.
And so, if the goal is to get bigger,
you want to focus not on getting bigger,
but on getting better, and then getting
bigger occurs. Growth occurs as a
result. Growth is not a goal. Growth is
an outcome of inputs.
And so, I'm telling you like it took me
a very long time to understand this. So,
I'm I'm trying to get like every
entrepreneur has this ego goal of like I
want to hit this a month, and I'll hit
that a month, and I'll hit that a month.
But the thing is just like you don't
want to make the income the goal. If you
do, it gets really hard to get out of
that game because sometimes you take the
wrong steps, you artificially inflate
revenue, and then you increase costs to
sustain that revenue, but it was the
wrong strategic move. And but then you
can't go backwards, you stay in the
cycle forever. You don't want to do
that. You have to think, "Okay, how do I
make the core thing that I do better?"
Because fundamentally, if this were
twice as good as it is now, would I be
bigger? Yes, because your customers
would demand it. You get far more
leverage by doing the same thing a
hundred times than doing a hundred
things one time. And so, the vast
majority of businesses, especially when
they're starting out, are doing a
hundred things one time rather than the
same thing a hundred times. And you get
a hell of a lot better when you do
something on the hundredth time. And so
that means that you drive up your
operational efficiency, you drive up
your gross profit, you get better at
your acquisition cuz your marketing
messaging, your sales scripting, the
results that you can promise, all those
things get better. And now you're
competing in a smaller pond so you can
dominate everyone. But when people think
small pond, they think that somehow that
means that they're not going to make a
lot of money. Like I said, Jim Wendler
makes a lot of money and it's in a very,
very, very, very, very narrow niche. And
so you just got to be more specific most
times and break the limiting beliefs you
have around the idea that like, okay,
well I just need to go from, you know,
I've saturated chiropractors, right?
I've I've saturated this with $2 million
a year in revenue. Of course not, right?
Every single other business that exists
that serves your customer, the fact that
they're allowed to be alive and breathe
shows you how much opportunity you have
if you were better than them. Number 10,
provide value. Now everybody talks about
providing value, what does that even
mean? All right, so in in this book I
talked about something called the value
equation, it's probably the most cited
chapter in this whole book. But I break
down what are the elements of value. And
so there are four. Number one is the
dream outcome, which is what does
somebody actually want? So if I were to
offer like
uh Daniel who's behind the camera right
now, I said, "Hey, you can get in shape
or I can make you a million dollars."
Right? Making money for most men is more
valuable than getting in better shape.
And so the relative opportunity or the
relative outcome will dictate how much
money you can charge. That's why in
general B2B offers are higher ticket.
Now there are also fewer people who buy
making money than people who buy
consumer products. So you have about
1/10th. So 9% of people are business
owners. Uh so you have a much smaller
market. That being said, does the the
the size of the market really matter
based on the thing I just said? Probably
not. But again, number one is dream
outcome. That's what differentiates. Now
let's say you've got two products that
offer the same solution. So let's say
the the the the weight loss example or
the getting shape example. If I have a
PDF for that and I've got uh
liposuction, both of them promise the
same thing, which is that you're going
to get in better shape, you're going to
lose weight. Okay, well then why is
liposuction so much more expensive than
a PDF that I could buy on the internet
for 20 bucks? They both promise the same
outcome. Well, there's three other
variables. So, variable number one is
the perceived likelihood of achievement
or the risk associated with the
purchase. So, risk would be the
negative, perceived likelihood of
achievement is the positive. And so, we
want to increase the perceived
likelihood as much as possible. So, if
we had that liposuction and we've got
one surgeon who's his first day out of
medical school and we got another
surgeon who's done 10,000 surgeries,
which of these guys can price higher?
Well, obviously, you'd want to take the
10,000 one even though it's the same
procedure and the same outcome. The
perceived likelihood of you actually
getting what you want, the risk
associated is lower, and so you're
willing to pay more for that guy cuz he
has more experience.
The third variable of this is time
delay. The equal opposite of that is
speed. How quickly between when someone
buys and when they get the promised
outcome. Now,
if you do liposuction, it's like, great.
You make the purchase and you go to
sleep and you wake up and you're thin.
Very, very condensed, which is why it
has a lot of value, right? Whereas if
you have to do all this eating and this
exercising and not drinking and changing
your diet and all this waking up early
and being sore, all this like there's a
lot of there's a lot of there's a lot of
delay there in terms of how much time
and effort it's time specifically is
going to take to get the outcome you
want. So, the faster it is, the more
valuable it is. And then finally, you
have effort and sacrifice or equal
opposite ease. How easy can you make it?
And so, if you're trying to think about
this in in in simple terms, it's how
risk-free can I make it? How easy can I
make it? How fast can I make it? And is
the thing that that I'm promising, the
outcome that I'm promising, something
they actually want? And so, if you have
all four of those, you have something
that people really want, they have no
risk of doing it, it comes immediately,
and it's easy. It's easy as pushing a
button, you've got an incredibly
valuable thing. And so, when people say,
"Add value," what you want to think
about is, "What does my customer or what
does my avatar want to accomplish or
what do they want to avoid?" So, you've
got towards good stuff and away from bad
stuff. And so, you say, "Okay, I can
help you avoid this bad stuff risk-free,
faster, and easier than otherwise." And
the dream outcome, the good stuff, same
thing again, is how can I help you get
that good stuff faster, easier, and
risk-free? And so, every time you make
content or every time you make a PDF, or
every time you make a lead magnet,
whatever it is, or you make content, the
whole goal should be to be useful. The
whole goal should be to provide value.
And you do that by helping them achieve
their goal, which hopefully with this
video I'm helping you market better your
business by making it risk-free so you
don't have to make the mistakes I did,
get to your goal faster, and get there
easier. So, the easiest way to think,
"Okay, got it. Well, how do I find the
problems that people are suffering from
so that I can make it faster, easier,
and risk-free for them?" Great question.
So, one is any comments that you get in
in response to content, that creates
more content. This is the endless
content wheel. It's like you make
content, people have questions about the
content, you make content about the
questions, they have questions about
those questions. The good thing is that
problems never end and people never stop
complaining. And so, as long as people
stop complaining and people have
problems, you're always going to have
problems to solve, which is one of the
nice things about being an entrepreneur.
You like humanity, if you told us
hundreds of years ago that we'd have the
internet in our hands and we'd have air
conditioning and Wi-Fi and all this
stuff, we'd be like, "Oh my god, all of
our problems are solved." But we have
more problems now than we did before cuz
we're more aware of the problems that
that we didn't know existed before. And
so, whenever you solve a problem, you
create another one. It's the
problem-solution cycle, it never ends.
And so, one is you can look at that. The
other is you can look internal to your
business, which is what are the what are
the things that people struggle with
internal in terms of implementation for
whatever the thing that you do is,
whether it's a product that you sell or
a service that you sell, there's some
friction points along the way. And you
think, "Okay, what are the friction
points and how can I make it easier?"
Number 11 is a fairly well-known
marketing saying, "Give away the
secrets, sell the implementation." The
way that I think about this is make your
free stuff better than their paid stuff.
And that's an easy ism to say, but the
real real is like you actually have to
think, "If I give away something for
free, I have to be willing to charge for
it." And if you were willing to charge
$100 or $1,000 or $10,000 for the thing
that you give away for free, my god,
must that be valuable. Yes. And what
that does is it increases the likelihood
of conversion. It increases the
likelihood that a person consumes the
thing and then buys the next product.
Because what a lead magnet is, or what
content is, it's a complete solution to
a very narrow problem. And that's
fundamentally how I think about this. A
lot of people are very afraid of giving
away value, but you shouldn't be. Give
away all the secrets. Give away all the
things that you do, and then if someone
wants help with implementation, they can
call you up. And this allows you to
provide value to the masses, build your
brand up, and then they use results in
advance as an approximation of the
results they're going to get after they
purchase. All right? And so, even when
you're marketing in terms of making
content, I like to think of being okay
with narrow
because deep is where the dollars are.
All right, so let me tell you let me
tell you a couple stories about this.
So, there was a lady who I just recently
met who was doing just under a million
dollars a year in profit. Profit from
5,800
followers on Instagram. She had no other
platform. She sourced 100% from
Instagram. And this blew my mind. I
mean, like I say this stuff, but having
having that level like it was such an
extreme example of tiny audience, big
money. It it broke my beliefs even
further than I already had them broken.
And when I looked at her page, here's
what's crazy. It wasn't like she had
crazy deep engagement, either. It was
like the post she would get would get,
you know, one, five, maybe 10 comments
on a great post.
And she would get, you know, 10 likes,
20 likes, 30 likes if it was a crazy
one.
But, 100% of her content was about how
registered dietitians can more
accurately bill insurance to make more
money. It was a niche of a niche. It was
literally like registered dietitians who
bill insurance and how to bill insurance
more effectively to make more per hour.
That was her offer, and that's all she
talks about. Her cheat sheets were on
that. Uh and she talks about different
insurance
uh companies and how to bill each of
them, the codes that you go that you
plug in like like all this jargon I had
no idea when I went to the page. But,
for her avatar, I'll bet you that of the
5,800 people that follow her, 5,700 of
them were registered dietitians who were
trying to find out what they needed to
do uh to make more money by billing
insurance. And so, she was selling five
to 10 uh little cheat sheets a day at
like 99 bucks plus two to three high
ticket people per week into her thing,
into her association of registered
dieticians that followed her process for
billing. And so, I say this because I've
also learned this personally. We used to
make some wider content for about 6
months. We did this We did this
experiment. We got the data back. It
turned out we got lots of views, but we
didn't get lots of business owners. And
so, we switched back to hardcore
business stuff, which I love anyway, so
I'm very happy about the experiment. And
because of that, all of our stats are
up. So, we have more opt-ins, more
people buying books, more people, you
know, going to work shops, whatever it
is, more people applying to the
portfolio, so we can invest in their
companies. All of those stats were up
despite the fact that the general views
per video went down. And again, I'm here
for the money, not for the fame. And so,
I encourage you, if you can break your
attachment to the ego metrics, like the
likes and the views and things like
that, and just focus on the bottom line,
just get really specific on the avatar
that you want to serve, and make content
only for them that's useful. So, I've
got a buddy of mine who runs a
multi-nine-figure-per-year
uh marketing company. And he makes
content online. He has a personal brand.
And he was like, "Oh, dude, my personal
brand makes no money." He's like, "But
And he goes super in-depth tactical like
stuff. He's an SEO G, and so all of his
stuff is like how to how to make SEO
content, blog content, things like that.
And his content gets like so few likes
and engagement. And he has like charts
and graphs and all this data to support
all he does. He's obviously really,
really good at this.
But the thing is this, he's his lead
quality that comes from him, he's like,
"They're all Fortune 500, Fortune 100
CEOs, executives that are like, 'Hey,
you obviously know this stuff. Can we
just hire you?'" And that's exactly who
he wants. He wants He He makes it so
complex. He gives away everything. And
he says it. He's like, "I give You could
just follow all my stuff and do it."
Most people are like, "Man, this is too
much work." And so, they're like, "Can I
just hire you?" Which is an exceptional
way to get customers.
So, here's how you do it in three easy
steps. One is you just give away your
best stuff. Give it all away. If you
have a low-ticket thing that sells to
lots of people, and high-ticket thing, I
would encourage you just give away the
low-ticket thing, too. You're probably
not making that much money on it
anyways, and those customers are
probably a pain in the butt. So, just
give it to them. And you can even show,
"Hey, I used to charge for this and I'll
give it to you for free cuz I love you."
All right? And by doing that, you make
an exceptional thing, and you put really
heavy
uh effort into follow-up and calls to
action within the within the content
itself. All right? So, within the thing
that you're giving away, you have CTAs,
and you follow up with your team to try
and ascend them in the next thing if
they're qualified. And I'll give you a
pro tip on this. When you want to make
the CTA, make it about personalization,
not about more. So, instead of saying,
"Hey, if you want more stuff like this,
go here." Say, "Hey, if you want me to
help apply this stuff to your business,
or apply this stuff to your body, or
this stuff to your life, then let me
know." It's personalizing it, cuz that
is significantly more valuable than just
more stuff. And what's crazy is that a
lot of people use the things they give
away as an afterthought. It's the last
thing they think about. But here's the
crazy stat, is that 99% of people who
consume your free thing will never buy
from you, which means that your
reputation's getting made by the 99% of
people, not the 1%. And so, if you want
to improve your reputation in the
marketplace, make sure the stuff that
you give away for free is awesome.
Also make sure the stuff that you sell
is awesome. And if both those things
sound like a four-letter word, which is
work, welcome to business.
And so, I talked earlier about going up
market or getting narrower on the avatar
that you want to serve. A lot of people
have down-sells, and I think over time
I've gotten less and less into having
down-sells, and more along lines of
like, if we have a lower avatar and
we're down-selling 10% of calls into
this thing that's paid, if 10% of people
are buying something that's 1/10 the
price cuz it's a down-sell, then it's
going to change my revenue by 1%. I
don't really care. It's not even worth
the headache. I'd rather just give that
away to hundreds of people for free,
because if the cost is free, way more
people will consume it, and then get a
higher percentage people to buy my next
thing, and I allow my marketing
messaging to attract the higher quality
customers. So, this is the last thing to
go up market or narrower, and give away
all the other stuff so I can create my
more qualified customers. The amount of
businesses that I know that one that
we've invested in or do that we've
helped
simply make way more money by just
giving away the thing that was their big
headache that was a low ticket thing
just so that they could focus on serving
the best customers.
Most times you'll make money going up
market. Marketing advice number 12, all
advertising works. It's just a matter of
efficiency. I'm really I like I want to
I want to drill this down people's
throats. The amount of time I've said
Facebook ads don't work for us. Google
ads don't work for us. TikTok ads don't
work for us. Direct mail doesn't work
for us. Radio ads don't work for us.
Content doesn't work for us. Outreach
doesn't work for us. Fundamentally,
if you have a qualified person on the
other side and you make an offer to them
that solves a key problem for them, if
you can get them on the phone, you can
make money, period. So, if you can
rephrase the problem as I don't know how
to make Facebook ads work for us. I
don't know how to make TikTok work for
us. I don't know how to make content
work for us. I don't know how to make
outreach work for us, then that becomes
a problem that you can solve. Now, this
is really important. So, I talked
earlier about optimizing your
advertising from front to back and
that's true. But, when you optimize a
business, you optimize it from back to
front. And so, the back, the LTV, how
much you make per customer enables how
much you can spend on the front end.
And so, you optimize the throughput on
the front end, obviously, because that's
where you get the highest returns, but
the engine that you can spend on that
depends on how much you make per
customer.
And so, you can either be really really
really exceptional at lowering CAC or
really really really good at increasing
LTV and if you do both,
you have huge arbitrage and that's where
you make stupid money. And so, let's go
through a hypothetical. Let's say that
you sold something that was a billion
dollar thing. Okay? If you have a
billion dollars in gross profit that
you'd make from one sale, you could
reach a lot of people on Earth. And just
to give you context on this, if I wanted
to become a A-list celebrity, uh I back
calculated what I believe it cost to
become an A-list celebrity. It was about
50 million dollars. And the way that I
calculated that was I thought, "What
person went from complete obscurity to
no one knew who they were, obscurity, to
omnipresence or some like that everybody
knew?" And so, the simplest example are
people who were no-name actors who
become the star of a big Marvel hit. And
so, what I did was I said, "Okay, how
many of these have I seen? What was the
movie budget?" Now, you have to divide
that by the other characters in the show
or in the in the movie. And between the
big blockbusters, where we had to you
think about like the Hunger Games girl,
right? I can't remember her name right
now, but that girl. Like, the marketing
budget for those types of films, you
think, "Okay, with $50 she went from no
knowing who she was to being famous."
And so, for $50 you can reach so much of
America. And so, I use this as a
hypothetical because if you had
something that you sold for a billion
dollars, you could spend that and still
make 20 to one.
And so, the idea is, yes, we optimize
our advertising from front to back. We
put our effort on the front. But, in
terms of where our our our LTV comes
from, we work from back to front so that
we can spend more on the front end. A
big problem in terms of efficiency is
that oftentimes, if you are if you do
start running ads profitably, for
example, you reach some sort of ceiling.
You're like, "Hey, we can't we can't get
past $2,000 a day. Hey, we can't get
past $10,000 a day. Hey, we can't get
past $100,000 a day." Whatever it is,
right? Usually, it's because the ads
that you have aren't good enough to
reach the next level of awareness. So,
Eugene Schwartz in Breakthrough
Advertising talked about something
called Five Levels of Awareness. And so,
they go from unaware, somebody has no
idea who you are, what the problem is,
or anything. They're just unaware. The
next level is problem aware. That's
where you see ads that are like, "Having
trouble sleeping at night? Do you have
back pain when you lean over?" Like,
things like that. They ask open-end
questions that make someone aware of the
problem.
Underneath of that is solution aware.
"Have you tried this before? Have you
tried this before?" This is where
someone knows the solutions that
potentially exist. Then you have product
aware, which is them advertising you
advertising your own product. Like,
"Okay, have you tried like my product
before? And let me talk you about this."
And then finally, you have most aware,
which is usually past and existing
customers. And so, those are five levels
of awareness.
And so, most times, smaller advertisers,
beginner advertisers, get returns
marketing to most aware, right? If you
email your list or you make a post or
you send out message
an email, right? Those are your most
aware people. So, you can make sales
from that for almost no money. One
degree above that is like, okay, well,
are there other people who are in the
market? That's product aware. They're
looking They're looking for something
uh to solve a specific problem, right?
Uh and they're aware of the options that
are out there and you market to them.
So, you have to be a little bit better
to market to those people than to just
your existing customers. Now, if you go
one level above that, right, solution
aware is that they know that there are
people who are solving this problem.
They don't know how they're solving the
problem. They know that there is a
solution that exists. And so, you have
to have another order of magnitude
improvement of your ads and the hooks to
call out those people. And so, most
times, the problem isn't that your
market isn't big enough, it's that your
ads aren't good enough and they're not
specific enough to hit this next massive
tranche of the audience. And I say this
with our largest company um in the
portfolio that is about $100 million a
year and we spend millions of dollars a
month in advertising and we go to the
most unaware people. We go to people who
have no idea that uh you know, this
product or this problem exists. We
actually have to make them aware of the
problem and then we make them aware of
the opportunity to solve it. And then we
have to make them aware of the problem.
We have to take them through all the
stages of awareness in a very short
period of time and that is come comes
from a very well-crafted ad. And so, I
have this saying that I have internal,
which is that the size of the plane is
directly correlated with the length of
the runway. The bigger the plane, the
longer the runway. And so, if you want
to sell a very expensive thing or you
want to sell a very cold person. So, the
price and the the coldness or how aware
the person is. So, the longest sale
possible would be somebody who's
completely unaware for a very expensive
thing, right? The shortest sale possible
would be someone who's very aware for a
very cheap thing. And so, the amount of
runway, the amount of selling, the
amount of advertising that you have to
do to get someone through these stages
is directly proportional to those two
things. And if you're having trouble
scaling, it usually means that this is
mismatched. You're trying to do You're
You're sending a warm message to a cold
audience or you're getting people on the
phone who aren't prepared to spend
a huge amount of money. They haven't
been warmed up enough. And so, it's
making sure that we're hitting each of
these boxes for the audience that we're
starting to target. And so, as you go to
a new tranche of Let's say you go from
uh solution aware to problem aware. So,
that's a that's a bigger area, right?
And so, think about this as concentric
circles like a pizza. Like the area of
the pizza, you know, like a pizza that's
this big, if you could take an inch off,
it's almost the same size as a as a 2-in
pizza in the middle. Like the the
diameter, circumference, whatever that
is. I probably failed geometry. The
point is is that um it just gets bigger
and exponentially bigger as you go out.
And so,
this is a weird visual that I have for
this. But, if you think about a
watermelon slice,
and at the tip there's lots of seeds.
And as you go down, there's fewer seeds.
But, you still have to pay the same
amount to reach all these eyeballs to
find the few seeds versus in the
beginning when you have lots of seeds.
So, your density of sales per thousand
eyeballs goes down as you go to more
unaware people. Because you're going to
go to people who just simply don't care
and never will care. But, you have to
and this is where the LTV matters so
much and the optimization matters so
much. But, you still if you can be
profitable in a larger tranche that's 10
or 100 times as big, that's when you
start really printing money. Right? And
so, if you have call it 20 to one LTV to
CAC in the beginning when you have lots
of little seeds, lots of density of
potential buyers, goods is really warm,
really problem aware or really really
solution or product aware, right? Like
really high end. As you go down, you
might drop to five to one in the middle.
You might drop to three to one at scale,
but you're at a hundred times the spend.
And so, in that case, you're still
making way more absolute return on the
investment. Another way to think about
this is like a golf course. And so, if
you could only putt, then you're going
to only make 6-in putts. That's only the
top little seeds of the watermelon. But,
think about how much more area if you
learned how to drive and you learned how
to hit a three iron. I'm not very good
at golf. You can obviously tell. And
then you hit learn how to hit a wedge.
There's so many more shots that you can
make if you have these other skills in
your arsenal. And so, think about each
of the levels of awareness as another
club that you have to learn how to hit
so that you can get more balls in the
hole from any part of the course.
Marketing advice number 13, we need to
be reminded more than we need to be
taught. And I think this is one that's
going to break a lot of your beliefs.
And so, I'm going to I want to really
emphasize this one cuz it's important.
Once you start making content, once you
start running ads, and you start putting
stuff out publicly, start advertising,
you're going to get to a point where
you're like, I feel like I've said
everything that I was going to say. Now,
remember, you continue to live life
every day, you continue to do stuff, and
you can talk about what you did, so that
can break that. But, my mom said this to
me once, and I I I always I always
remembered it. She said, "The news never
changes, just the names." And I really
thought about that. It was like, there's
always a rape, there's a war, there's a
murder, there's a car accident. Like,
the actual story doesn't change, only
the names.
And so, if you think about that with
content, like, there is no new content.
Like, the human condition has not
changed for thousands of years. Like,
the older the problem, the older the
solution. And so,
we're
making content, and we're putting stuff
out there,
and when I think about myself, the
things that I follow, like, I follow
philosophy pages because I am okay
rereading Epictetus's stuff. Like, I
read his stuff before, and I read it in
quote form again, and when it comes up
again, I like to be reminded. I like to
keep the stuff top of mind. That's why I
follow those pages. And many people
follow your pages for that exact same
reason, is that the stuff you talk about
is stuff that they want to keep top of
mind. They want to be reminded of that
stuff. And getting taught is much more
difficult than being reminded, but
they're equally valuable. Because if it
changes their behavior, then you still
did teach them. Again, you just reminded
them. And what's crazy about this is
that, like, the Friends show right now,
if you've ever heard of it, is being
watched more now than it was a few years
ago.
So, reruns. Like, people watch reruns
because there's nostalgia or whatever
reasons you want to pick to it, but
people are willing to rewatch the same
thing because they know how it ends,
they know they liked it.
And so,
you can make the same thing again
because also, your audience who's new a
year later hasn't seen that thing. And
so, if you make something new to them,
even though it's  old or reminder
to your existing audience, your existing
audience doesn't mind the reminder, and
the new people never saw it to begin
with. And if you want to have different
ways of creating variety, even around
the same topics, I would encourage you,
instead of thinking of
getting into trend hacking and talking
about the news, talk about your news.
So, it's about what are the new things
that are happening now. This is the do
epic stuff, talk about what you did. And
so, this is where we tell new stories to
explain the same concept because for
that specific audience, you'll reach a
different type of person or different
avatar that still may be within your
market with a story about a mother and a
daughter versus a father and a son
versus a military vet versus
a small business owner, right? There are
different avatars and you can tell the
same story, but it happens to a
different name, just like the news. And
people still watch the news every single
day, and then what we want is them to
watch our news. You can tell the same
concept like the value equation. The
value equation I explained in my book. I
also have a course on my site that I
explain the value equation in a
different format. So, think about it in
terms of formats. This is written. I
have an audio. I've got videos that are
on my site that are in a course format.
I'm mentioning it here now. I have it on
whiteboards that I've explained it. I've
applied it to services. I've applied it
to education. I've applied it to
physical products. I've applied it to
software. And so, you can take the same
idea and think how can I display it in
new formats, new mediums, and new
contexts. And so, when you have that and
then you extrapolate on top the news of
your life, even though you feel like
it's saying the same thing, the amount
that it takes to create something novel
is very small. And so, I'll tell you the
story that I think will wrap this up.
It's the story of Henry Ford.
And so, Henry Ford had in his office, he
had his marketing person right next to
him. So, he walked past the marketing
department over and over and over again.
And this is back in the day when they
like didn't have computer screens. So,
it was just like they had mock-ups and
like big posters and things like that
for whatever the next ad campaign for a
new Ford car was. And so, he walked past
this guy's office for 3 months. At the
end of the 3 months, he was like, "Hey
John, when are we going to stop running
this ad? I'm so sick of it." And John,
the marketing director looked at him and
said, "We haven't even started running
it yet." And so, the thing is is that we
get so much sicker of our own content
before our audience even remembers your
name.
And so, the thing is is that we assume
that every person consumes every piece
of content you ever put out. We put out
50 plus pieces of content a day. I'm
grateful if somebody watches one a week,
right? And so, the idea here is that
like you put out significantly more, but
we have this assumption that everyone's
paying attention and no one is. And so,
we put out tons of volume with the hope
that we catch one person on that one
day. And you might have make I might
have made four things about the value
equation. Actually, you can give me good
feedback, so this will be good. If you
haven't heard about the value equation
whatsoever in my content up to this
point, drop a comment cuz I want to I
want to prove that this, even though
I've talked about it in a zillion
formats, some of you guys didn't even
know how to book, right?
People need to be reminded more than
need to be taught. And for those of you
who don't know, the mission
acquisition.com is to make real business
education accessible for everyone. And I
spent the last 4 years plus making
content and hopefully giving away all
the stuff you need to scale your
business. And I love getting the
messages and the stories that we do. But
it would mean the world to me if you
just share this video with another
business owner who they can hopefully
compress 13 years into however long this
video ends up being to save them all the
scars and so they can just have the
lessons. Thank you.